Pero mi idea es que contratamos seguros
para cubrirnos económicamente
si esto sucediera, ¿sí?
Por eso al hacer inversiones sustentables
estamos haciendo 2 cosas.
Estamos creando un seguro,
reduciendo el riesgo para nuestro planeta y para nuestra economía,
y al mismo tiempo, a corto plazo,
no estamos sacrificando el rendimiento.
[Hombre en la tira: "¿Y si es broma y hacemos un mundo mejor para nada?"]
Bueno, les gustó. A mí también.
(Risas)
Me gusta porque se ríe
de los dos lados del cambio climático.
¿A que adivinan de qué lado estoy?
Pero lo que más me gusta
es que me hace acordar a algo que dijo Mark Twain:
"Planea para el futuro,
porque ahí es donde vas a pasar
el resto de tu vida".
Gracias.
(Aplausos)